for every horror movie that gets a
mainstream audience there it doesn't
that fly under the radar in the release
so where can you find all the great
horror movies you've never heard of one
word Netflix these underrated horror
gems never got the attention they
deserved but now you can revel in all
the terror they have to offer from the
comfort of your living room holidays
anthology horror has been making a
comeback in this dark riff on seasonal
celebrations is one of the lesser-known
gems in the genre eight different
directors including Kevin Smith and Gary
Shore contributed to a creepy pint-sized
nightmare on a holiday theme like most
anthology films not every one of these
scary stories will hit home but that's
also part of the charm the wildly
inventive storylines and diverse
approaches showcased in each of its
short films make holidays the kind of
movie that has something for everyone
hard candy long before she was a
well-known name in Hollywood Ellen Page
was the young star of this immensely
disturbing movie about a
fourteen-year-old girl who's targeted by
a middle-aged predator played by Patrick
Wilson only for the predator to realize
he's the hunted not the hunter Paige
carries the movie to a crazy conclusion
that left no question about her star
potential at the time the controversial
premise and minuscule budget made hard
candy a tough sell when it came to a
traditional release but despite being
awarded overlooked film of the year at
the 2006 Phoenix Film Critics society
Awards the movie has continued to be a
hidden and little-seen gem curve in this
horror flick about a road trip gone
wrong julianne hough stars as Mallory a
bride-to-be whose car breaks down in the
wild and route to her wedding rehearsal
when a charming but sadistic hitchhiker
enters the picture Mallory's last hurrah
as a single girl turns into a fight for
survival she crashes her car and ends up
trapped at the bottom of a Gulch
while the hitchhiker who survived the
crash returns periodically to taunt her
curves should have made a bigger splash
than it did but it got lost in early
2016 and went straight to streaming
however the theaters lost was Netflix's
game so catch it on the streaming
service before it disappears round the
bend the Lazarus effect released in 2015
this movie about a serum that can bring
people back to life was almost
completely overlooked on sheer star
power alone
the Lazarus effect is virtually
unmatched as an under-the-radar horror
movie with Olivia Wilde mark Duplass
donald glover sarah Bolger and Evan
Peters all working their magic to
elevate a less than inspired concept
into legitimately scream worthy
territory and while it's true that the
script could be tighter don't believe
the lack of hype on this one the Lazarus
effect is a far better movie than its
low rating on Rotten Tomatoes would
suggest 1922 Netflix definitely knew
what it was doing when it snagged this
little story for a screen adaptation
based on a novella from Stephen King's
full dark no stars anthology 1922 stars
Thomas Jane as Wilfred James a farmer
living in rural Nebraska during the
period leading up to the Great
Depression money troubles and marital
conflict lead wilfred to some very dark
places and it just goes to show that
sometimes getting away with a crime is
much worse than getting caught that
murdered my wife to keep my home the
only way I was leaving it now would be
in change like many of Stephen King's
best works this is a character-driven
horror and strong performances make a
stand out particularly from Jane who
immerses himself in the role so
thoroughly that it's hard to believe
this same miserable hate you and Yoko is
the same cosmopolitan pretty boy from
the sweetest thing you're never gonna
find anyone better than my brother Eyrie
is the greatest and I am scared not just
just look at them chicks freak on this
guy creeped in 2014 filmmaker Patrick
Brice set out to answer the question
what's the worst thing that could happen
from meeting someone on Craigslist
without spoiling anything let's just say
the answer is something really bad
that's what a videographer discovers
when he goes to the home of Joseph
played by Mark Duplass who also co-wrote
and produced a movie for what's supposed
to be a documentary project what starts
out as the ordinary weirdness of
internet strangers becomes something
much more disturbing that's peach fuzz
that's it's just peach fuzz say hello
the result is a movie that more than
lives up to its title
Gerald's game with so many blockbusters
on the big screen in 2017 you might have
missed some of the smaller adaptations
of Stephen King's works including this
one based on the 1992 novel of the same
name
Gerald's game centers on a woman who
ends up trapped hadn't cuffed to the bed
at her lake house after her husband has
a heart attack as she struggles to find
a way to escape she's visited by a
series of entities some real some
imagined and some that seem to straddle
the line between this world and the next
[Music]
one of Netflix's original feature films
Gerald's game was eagerly anticipated by
hardcore King fans but didn't get the
kind of widespread attention merited by
its creativity in star power despite the
obvious challenges of holding down an
entire two-hour film on her own actress
carla Gugino keeps it riveting making
this the finest horror movie set almost
entirely on a bed since well maybe ever
unless you count bet at the day a dark
song this Irish independent horror movie
flew under the radar when it was
released in 2017 but the handful of film
buffs who did see it were impressed and
with good reason a dark song centers on
a grieving mother who hires an occultist
to guide her through a complex
months-long right at a remote home in
the Welsh countryside despite a teensy
budget and a very green director at a
tone a dark song boasts incredible
production values and phenomenal sound
work that subverts the usual tried and
true horror film tropes instead the film
revels in the slow burn and deliberately
draws out the tension in the end this
entry is a deep dark and gorgeously
acted meditation on loss that builds
into a harrowing and unexpected climax
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]